ukrainian forces have been fighting back
against russian assaults on the
outskirts of kiev authorities are urging
citizens to defend the capital weapons
including guns are being given out to
residents the ukrainian army says it
repelled an assault on a military base
in the capitol russia says it has
launched a barrage of cruise missiles
and rockets against ukraine
[Music]
an early morning missile strike on a
residential block in kiev
here's the moment of impact from inside
one of the apartments
while russia says it's only targeting
military facilities ukrainian officials
call this a cynical attack on civilian
infrastructure
no deaths have yet been reported
but for some it was very close
it was a direct hit into the living room
we were lucky to escape because we were
in the kitchen my wife and our older
child have had their legs broken the
younger one was taken somewhere by the
rescuers i'm looking for him now
and that's why many civilians are
sheltering in basements
or fleeing altogether
streaming towards ukraine's western
borders
one hundred thousand have crossed into
poland this week
as they seek a safe haven in the eu
their president wants the regional bloc
to go one further and fast track
ukraine's membership
residential buildings destroyed by
missiles and artillery are the final
argument for the world to join us in
stopping this occupational invasion
i say it as frankly as possible the
ukrainian people deserve and have the
right to get membership of the european
union
this will be the main evidence of
support for our country
still his forces claim they're repelling
the russian advance
moscow says it's launching missiles from
both the air and sea
the two countries fighting a propaganda
battle as the war rages on
let's speak now to andrea yeska a
reporter specializing in crises
migration and human rights who joins us
now from ukraine she's on the phone
because she says she's at a secret
location which of course she can't
disclose uh andrea tell us what's been
happening around you
we are standing in front of our ikea's
main police station at the moment and
there's a long long queue of mainly
young men who want to join the
territorial defense and go in there and
come back out with ammunition and
kalashnikov
and they all say they're going to fight
until the end and they are ready to
sacrifice their life for the country and
they all persuaded that they can
beat the russians we heard some
artillery fire this morning in the city
about five or six streets away from
where we are staying it came from two
sides so it seems there are street
there's street fighting going on already
and
people are desperately
buying food in the few shops that are
still open but everything is mainly gone
it's it's hard to get anything to eat
anymore everything is closed of course
the metro is not running anymore so the
city is very very quiet right now
uh i just want to ask you very quickly
about those men that you saw
essentially enlisting uh was there a
look of resolve in these in these
people's eyes or was there just a sense
of this is their duty
well i think they they consider it their
duty they are not really willing to talk
to us this is something that we have
experienced in the past two days
also that uh the sentiment against
europe is quite bad right now people
feel
that we deserted them they feel helpless
they are asking us why we don't do
anything and why we don't help so they
are not really eager to talk to western
journalists anymore most of them and
yesterday we had a scene where we were
there there was alarm and we went one of
the bunkers and we were told to go
because they didn't want europeans there
so yeah that's that's how people feel
here now
they they really feel feel deserted by
europe
your journalists what are your fears now
regarding press freedom and the ability
of the media to report on what's
happening in the country
i think the problem is that the news
will come
within seconds and nobody can follow
really anymore what's going on the
interesting thing is that within the
city it is really hard to know what is
going on there are just so many rumors
going around and people of course pick
up these rumors and there's a lot of
[ __ ] that is being told here was
what supposedly is happening which when
you do some fact checking is not true
but yes
emotions are high and people are not
very
very
very
sensible anymore about what they say
understood uh that's uh andrea jeska in
ukraine many thanks and stay safe of
course
okay thanks a lot
russian president vladimir putin has
repeated a call to ukrainian soldiers to
surrender also making baseless
accusations against the ukrainian
government
once again i appeal to the servicemen of
the armed forces of ukraine do not allow
neo-nazis to use your children your
wives and elderly as human shields
take power into your own hands it seems
that it would be easier for us to come
to an agreement than with this gang of
drug addicts and new nazis who settled
in kiev and took the entire ukrainian
people hostage
journalist sergey sadanovsky joins me
now from moscow sergey
putin there of course calling on the
ukrainian armed forces to stage a coup
essentially what's the feeling in russia
as to how putin's war is going
the reactions in right inside russia are
very different you can see jubilation
only on state-run tv channels
there the propaganda machine says that
russia is acting like a great power like
the usa
they also dehumanize ukrainian officials
you could hear it yesterday the
president president putin
called
ukrainian leaders as a
a bunch of junkies
yes but um also
uh
people
feel different feelings i mean i spoke
to the people who live in belgrade they
sit next to the border with ukraine
and they have been living under stress
for several days seeing dance just
outside their windows
and for last three days they can hear
the sound of explosions that also cause
windows trembling so it's very stressful
for them and you also can see
people get out to the streets of moscow
saint petersburg and other
cities of russia that protest against
the invasion of ukraine
i understand the kremlin has moved to
tighten restrictions on social media
most notably access to facebook what
more can you tell us
yes lots of people cannot uh access
facebook well uh
and also twitter
uh russian media watchdog roscomm nazar
says that it is a reaction to
facebook blocking russian
uh state-run
tv channels like zvezda and also some
uh
in the uh
mass media like uh lentaru and
uh gazetaru
uh but also a lot of independent mass
media in expect that they can blow can
be blocked in
just recent hours because uh
war
while talking about the conflict uh in
ukraine they said it is
russian military operation in ukraine
and that's what
every mass media in russia should use
we've seen protests in many russian
cities how broad is the opposition to
this war in russia
it seems like it is
a huge position in russia
thousands of
scientists journalists
even doctors and teachers
sign letters open letters petitions
against the war
also a lot of celebrities prominent
people in russia like singers
writers
post anti-war publications on instagram
they post black square and say no to war
so it seems like opposition is really
great in russia
really appreciate your time and
perspective journalists sergey
satranovsky many many thanks
thank you
the european union has already imposed
economic sanctions on russia french
naval forces have now intercepted a
cargo vessel loaded with cars heading
for russia they suspect it belongs to a
company targeted by the sanctions
president emmanuel macron fears the war
in ukraine will have lasting
consequences for europe
if i can tell you one thing this morning
it is that this crisis will last this
war will last and all the crises that
come with it will have lasting
consequences and so we must prepare for
this with great determination and great
solidarity
german chancellor olaf schultz is
meeting with poland's prime minister and
lithuania's president here in berlin to
discuss further sanctions on russia
western nations have already imposed a
wide range of sanctions following the
invasion of ukraine on friday both the
u.s and the eu announced plans to put
sanctions directly on president vladimir
putin and his foreign minister sergey
lavrov but the polish government says it
wants the eu to go further and sanction
russia much more harshly we're joined
now in the studio by our political
correspondent thomas sparrow thomas
german chancellor schultz met with the
leaders of poland and lithuania today
how significant is this meeting it is
very significant and we already heard
from poland's leader why he actually
came to berlin he said that he wanted to
shake germany's conscience asking
germany to leave its selfishness aside
strong extremely strong words from
poland's leader towards uh germany's
olaf schultz in particular what poland
wants you already mentioned one of the
two elements is much stronger sanctions
towards russia one of the key elements
there is germany's reluctance to
go with other european countries and ban
russia from the swift financial system
the second element which poland wants is
for germany to send
weapons to ukraine it is by the way a
request that ukraine has stressed many
times and so far germany has only
promised to send 5000 helmets in fact
those 5 000 helmets were delivered on
friday from germany to ukraine there's a
big debate here in this country as to
why germany has so far
not sent any weapons to ukraine as other
countries have done like the united
states or like the united kingdom and
let's go back to that ban on the swift
financial system germany is holding out
here in europe please explain what the
thinking is on that essentially what
germany believes is that by doing that
by
blocking russia from the swift system
there will be significant collateral
damage i'm quoting here germany's
foreign minister elena book in
particular because this system is used
not only for german businesses that uh
carry out business affairs with with
russia but also for payments on gas
deliveries and there's a specific fear
that has been expressed for example by
germany's finance minister that gas
deliveries to germany could be cut if
indeed the european union decides to ban
russia from this swift system however
germany has stressed that they are open
to discussing
taking russia out of swift as long as
the consequences for specific european
countries are also taken into
consideration so germany is one of the
few european union countries that still
remains hesitant when it comes to this
swift decision and everybody here in
europe is very nervous about what's
going on with energy sources right now
uh you know we're also hearing about um
the first group of basically
refugees leaving ukraine as a result of
this conflict having arrived here in
germany what more can you tell us about
that and this is actually another big
and potentially difficult element of
this whole crisis
united nations estimates say that
already over a hundred thousand people
have fled uh ukraine uh that if their
estimates prove to be correct if the war
continues if the war intensifies they
there could be up to four million people
leaving
ukraine and the first people fleeing the
war in ukraine have already arrived here
in germany in particular in the in the
eastern part of the country so in the
german state that borders with poland
already officials they're stressing that
they're preparing for the arrival of
around 10 000 people the first families
have also arrived here in berlin berlin
officials also saying that they're
preparing for for this arrival so
there's also a lot happening in in that
regard preparing for the arrival of
people who are fleeing the war in
ukraine an onslaught um thomas sparrow
thank you so much
now many of the people caught up in the
invasion have fled to neighboring
countries tens of thousands of
ukrainians have already left most are
headed to countries bordering ukraine
these include eu members poland slovakia
hungary romania as well as non-member
moldova as fighting worsens these
nations are now bracing for more
refugees in the coming days
the train station in the polish city of
shemeshol 10 kilometers from ukraine
for many ukrainian refugees it's their
first stop after crossing the border
these four children are having their
first hot meal in 30 hours after
traveling 450 kilometers through ukraine
their fathers weren't able to join them
they stayed behind to fight the children
are now waiting for their mothers to
arrive
there were masses of people on the way
we took a bus towards the border and
then walked then we stood in a long
queue
suddenly we saw our cousins and we've
been together since then
we waited a long time for the transport
from the border
and now we're finally here
the way was hard and long
because of traffic jams they had to get
off the bus and walk the last 15
kilometers to the border
near leve they heard explosions
it was terrible there were rockets
flying
we came here without passports we only
have our birth certificates we were let
into poland as refugees
the polish authorities have decided to
let all ukrainians into the country even
those who have no passports which are
normally required to enter the eu
at the train station as well as in
several reception centers they are
supported by volunteers and the military
the refugees are relieved to have
escaped the war
but they're also worried about what they
have left behind the events in their
country
those who are not picked up here by
friends or relatives are taken in by
private individuals
the willingness to help is great
within a day of the russian invasion
thirty thousand refugees arrived in
poland from ukraine the government in
warsaw expects that up to one million
people could flee to the country and it
promises that they will all be taken in
let's bring in now dw correspondent max
zander who is at a the train station in
shemeshol
max more than a hundred thousand
ukrainian refugees have already arrived
in poland
describe the situation there
well we're at the train station here in
chemistry as you rightly pointed out and
it just became a lot more busy um over
the last last few minutes uh the last
train from ukraine just came in and
brought a lot of new people and people
here actually uh polish locals and
people from the city council
firefighters as well as soldiers are
working very hard to provide provide
help provide immediate donations like
these food donations over here and
services to the people
here who arrive here at the airport so
they're handling out food but they're
also helping them with their next travel
arrangements um trying to
bring them together with family and
relatives if there are some in poland or
neighboring countries or if not help
them with accommodation bring them to
some of the reception centers that have
been put in place uh here in the country
and the interior minister deputy
interior minister of poland uh came to
the area this morning and spoke to the
press and said i pointed out more than a
hundred thousand people um already have
crossed from ukraine to poland and
they're likely going to be a lot more um
numbers conservative estimates were
about 1 million but perhaps they're
going to be even more than that
but it seems that authorities are and
locals are doing their uttermost to to
provide assistance to the people who
have come here already
max it's literally buzzing there i can't
imagine that there's going to be a let
up anytime soon the refugees are often
on the road for hours i imagine they
arrive having not slept or eaten much
what condition are they in
that's absolutely right i mean people
people are leaving ukraine for a reason
people are anxious people have fear
people have experienced trauma perhaps
but also
they are just very exhausted the trip
through ukraine and then also the last
lake crossing the border um takes takes
a lot of time the land crossings um have
been particularly difficult uh the car
crossings um because there have been a
huge pileups of traffic people had to
leave their cars and and walk the last
few kilometers to cross the border so
people who arrived there are naturally
very exhausted um in addition to that uh
the ukrainian authorities um
made it uh
changed the the the crossings the style
of the crossings that you cannot cross
by car um from ukraine to poland any
longer because a lot of the drivers were
male and uh they're trying to keep
anybody at the fighting age between 18
and 60 in the country so now um people
who leave ukraine and cross the border
to poland actually have to walk or if
they come by train
here to the train station it's also very
difficult um because you're dealing with
a lot of checks
for for the same reason and a lot of
delays so people here are
in a very difficult state
max i wonder how do people on the ground
in poland actually view this attack in
ukraine um are they are they angry or is
there fear that perhaps russia may may
have them in its sights
i mean that's that's difficult to say i
mean everybody
everybody uh
across the board is is worried um that's
for sure um there
have has been uh
his historic um
uh mistrust to uh
to to to russia for especially some
older parts of the polish generation um
so people are viewing very close what's
happening and a lot of people are afraid
that this that violence may spill over
and that perhaps um being in the
european union and being a nato might
not be enough protection after all but
at the moment uh the situation is it's
very fast moving of course and people
are obviously worried and watching very
close to what's happening
max zander with a group of very tired
and hungry people there in shemeshol
many many thanks
dw correspondent funny fachar joins us
on the line and actually we see pictures
of her there
she is she was in kiev but is no longer
there has moved to another location
altogether uh funny tell us where you
are and uh what's going on around you
i mean kamenetzky which is about
normally about four hours from kiev it
actually took us 14 hours yesterday to
get here and what you actually see
behind me is normally a theater but it's
no longer theater but it has become a
refugee center for internally displaced
people from all all regions of ukraine
trying to find a shelter here now on the
other side just across from this shelter
you see a long long line of people
volunteers a man of all ages trying to
sign up to help ukraine defend itself
what's happening really here in
hamanetsky is something it also also
tells you
what the situation right now is in
ukraine and that is a combination of
panic a combination of
and and and still i hope though that it
may not go as far as as a lot of people
are worried that it may that this is
going to be a war for a long long long
time to come people are hoping that
there is going to be a negotiation
between ukraine and russia to prevent
the death and the further bloodshed
among civilians among soldiers and
everyone involved here in this situation
in ukraine
and funny as we saw those images of
people who are now displaced you get the
sense that this is certainly just the
beginning um what have you heard from
ukraine's capital kiev
what's happening in keefe is is
basically just a big mess right now
people are panicking they are trying to
find shelter go to the metro station the
mayor of kiev declared that all metros
are going to not are not going to
operate any longer they are only
operating as bunkers as shelters now we
have seen of course
heart-wrenching pictures of children
huddling together scared and it is a
very very critical situation as we are
hearing that the
russian military troops are building up
around the city
apparently only 30 kilometers from the
city center there's a heavy russian
troop built up but already there are
russian soldiers in on the ground in
kiev so it's expected that street fights
between ukrainian and russian forces are
about to begin or even to escalate at
the same time the president president
zielenski appeared in a video on social
media early this morning basically
trying to show i'm still here i'm not
going to lay down arms uh because he
said rumors have it that people think
that he is going to urge people to lay
down their arms and dimitri
militarize as it's being expected by a
russian president vladimir putin so a
lot of chaos and in fact what is
engulfing right now keith and it's
really unclear what the next hours are
going to bring there just like it's
unclear what's going to happen to the
rest of the country and there's so many
explosions across the country in
various regions even though the most
intense shelling so far still is in the
east and in the southern and in the
northern parts of ukraine
okay that's uh dw's funny for char many
many thanks funny and please stay safe
you're watching dw news here's the main
story we're following for you
recapping the latest developments uh
ukraine's military says it repelled an
assault by russian troops on an army
base in vassal kev about 40 kilometers
south of kiev the mayor says there were
heavy casualties russian news agency
interfax reports that its forces have
taken control of the ukrainian city of
melatopal if confirmed this would be the
first major city to fall street fighting
continues in the capital kiev intense
gunfire and explosions rocked the city
overnight
a missile has struck an apartment block
in a kiev suburb that russian forces
were attempting to capture russia says
it is firing rockets and cruise missiles